[Música]
hola bienvenidos aquí a américa el
espacio de france 24 dedicado a revisar
en profundidad las noticias de nuestro
continente es hoy santiago ariztía en
reemplazo de mi compañera natalia
cabrera y estos son los temas que vamos
a abordar en esta emisión en brasil
desde la llegada al poder de jair
bolsonaro se han incrementado los
ataques a la prensa no sólo los verbales
por parte del mandatario sino que
incluso sus seguidores los llevan al
plano físico y el equipo de france 24 en
río de janeiro que lo sufrió en carne
propia nos cuenta más de la corte
suprema de méxico declaró
inconstitucionales varios artículos que
impedían el consumo el cultivo y la
distribución de marihuana lo que deja a
este país norteamericano a un paso más
cerca del uso recreativo ilegal del
cannabis todo un hito para un país que
ha vivido la violencia de la guerra
contra las drogas y hay vida allá afuera
realizamos un nuevo informe de los
servicios de inteligencia de eeuu que
revela que de 144 avistamientos de
objetos voladores no identificados desde
2004 hasta 2021 tan sólo uno pudo ser
explica
y vamos ahora al sur del continente en
brasil para nuestra historia principal y
es que desde que ganó las elecciones en
octubre de 2018
el presidente de jair bolsonaro no ha
parado de atacar a los periodistas
inspirados en el ex presidente de eeuu
donald trump
bolsonaro considera a la prensa como su
principal enemigo sin embargo en los
últimos meses las agresiones contra
reporteros casi siempre de televisión
han empeorado bastante y la consecuencia
es que en las calles los seguidores del
mandatario brasileño también agreden a
estos profesionales nos cuenta más
nuestro equipo en río de janeiro este
globo es una moda de prensa
ustedes son una porquería de prensa
calla la boca ustedes son unos canallas
este es el presidente de brasil
actitudes como estas son cada vez más
habituales
en las calles los periodistas son
agredidos con frecuencia por los fans de
jair bolsonaro sobre todo en las
manifestaciones a favor del presidente
sólo el año pasado en brasil fueron
contabilizadas 367 alertas de violación
de la libertad de prensa una por día
este periodista denuncia una estrategia
sistemática de ataques por parte del
gobierno para deslegitimar a la prensa
consecuencias permanente una de las
consecuencias de este tipo de presión
permanente es la autocensura de empresas
o de periodistas individuales
ips
que piensan dos o tres veces antes de
publicar alguna información que
consideran que podría tener como
consecuencia alguna represalia física o
financiera física o financiera
la policía también intimida a los
periodistas en mayo una acción represiva
en una favela de río de janeiro acabó
con la vida de 27 vecinos
el editor de la revista de intercept
escribió un reportaje que denunciaba la
existencia de una célula de matones
dentro del cuerpo de asalto de la
policía acto seguido la policía civil
abrió una investigación contra él
leandro es un periodista amenazado que
hace dos años tiene guardaespaldas que
es un policía de represión de la
libertad de prensa de la libertad de
expresión y es una política de represión
del pensamiento ellos expresando
pensamiento en los últimos tiempos esta
comisaría se ha dedicado a perseguir a
los comunicadores y a periodistas que
denuncian correctamente los problemas y
las lacras de brasil cifras más reales
brasil
desde qué bolsonaro llegó al poder
brasil ha bajado cuatro puntos en el
ranking de libertad de prensa de la ong
reporteros sin fronteras
incluso nuestro equipo sufrió en sus
propias carnes esta realidad durante la
cobertura de una manifestación
y continuamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente en méxico porque la corte
suprema de la nación azteca dio pasos
hacia la despenalización del uso
recreativo de la marihuana
la decisión de declarar como
inconstitucionales varios artículos de
la carta magna- añade presión al senado
del país para que legisle al respecto
una ley que tendría un inmenso cambio
para los mexicanos que han sido testigos
de años de violencia entre cárteles del
narcotráfico
activista celebran en las afueras de la
corte suprema de méxico después de que
los jueces dieran un paso adelante en la
despenalización del uso recreativo del
cannabis
willy es un día histórico para las
libertades después de un largo camino y
esta suprema corte consolida el derecho
al libre desarrollo de la personalidad
para el uso lúdico recreativo de la
marihuana 8 de los 11 magistrados
respaldaron la decisión al considerar
que la prohibición actual es
inconstitucional en marzo la cámara baja
del parlamento mexicano aprobó un
proyecto de ley que legalizaba el uso
recreativo del cannabis pero desde
entonces estaba estancado en el senado
la orden de la corte significa que todos
los adultos pueden ahora aplicar a un
permiso para cultivar y consumir su
propia marihuana pero no discrimina liza
la producción posesión o transporte de
la droga hemos aclarado hoy hemos dicho
estos no desde plantas
y esto no es de gramos es de derechos
humanos pero hay otros más cautelosos
que creen que la ley deja a los
consumidores en un vacío legal hasta que
se legisla al respecto habría un área
gris porque no hay legislación la
suprema no legisla ellos solo están
tachando artículos que son
inconstitucionales el movimiento por la
legalización busca poner fin a la
violencia relacionada con los cárteles
de la droga que cobran miles de vidas en
méxico cada año y quiere además dar un
golpe a los grupos criminales que
controlan su producción sin embargo los
narcotraficantes están dejando de
cultivar cannabis para producir drogas
duras como cocaína y heroína que son más
lucrativas y docenas de personas
murieron en canadá debido a una
histórica ola de calor las temperaturas
alcanzaron cifras récord de más de 49
grados centígrados de acuerdo con la
autoridad nacional de metereología el
aumento se debe a un sistema de presión
que no está circulando les explicamos de
qué se trata
vancouver columbia británica se cocina
por una histórica ola de calor la
temperatura promedio entre junio y julio
de unos agradables 21 grados se ha
duplicado recientemente con la aledaña
lipton rompiendo el recorte histórico
canadiense hasta alcanzar los 49 puntos
5 grados el oeste de canadá está siendo
horneado por lo que se conoce como domo
de calor que ya ha causado cientos de
muertes
y habrá mucha más gente en el hospital y
muy enferma porque algunos de ellos no
saben cómo cuidarse afirma el cachet en
soft
cuando el calor se acerca a la
superficie de la tierra generalmente se
disipa a medida que se eleva pero cuando
los sistemas de alta presión forman la
atmósfera superior
el calor es empujado hacia abajo
calentándose más a medida que es
comprimido al nivel de la tierra
el ciclo crea un domo de aire caliente
que vuelve a circular y cuya alta
presión empuja los vientos marítimos y
las nubes así que podrían aliviar las
temperaturas el efecto también se siente
más al sur en la costa pacífica de eeuu
que alcanza a temperaturas récord o por
igual este no es un problema de columbia
británica no es un problema de canadá es
un reto global todos tenemos que hacer
que ciudadanos del mundo se unan porque
tenemos que atender una pandemia global
tenemos que regular nuestros esfuerzos
para atender el calentamiento global y
sus consecuencias en la gente las
comunidades tienen paisajes que los
domos de calor no son causados
directamente por el calentamiento global
pero empeoran con las sequías que si
están relacionadas con el cambio
climático
empeoran a medida que el planeta se
calienta la reciente ola de calor de
norteamérica también está elevando la
preocupación sobre la venidera temporada
de incendios se prevé que sea más larga
y peor que nunca
y un anticipado informe de la
inteligencia estadounidense sobre
objetos voladores no identificados no
arroja conclusiones y es que de 144
avistamientos de ovnis entre 2004 y 2009
21 los investigadores sólo pudieron
explicar uno lo que significa que no se
puede descartar que se trate de naves
extraterrestres
estas imágenes infrarrojas de la armada
de estadounidenses registradas en 2015
muestran uno de los más de 140
avistamientos de misteriosos objetos
voladores registrados en los documentos
desclasificados del pentágono explica
uno de ellos para otros el ejército
estadounidense tiene sólo una certeza
de 'la dictaminado que estos
avistamientos que fueron vistos por
pilotos de la armada eran algún tipo de
programa secreto del gobierno
estadounidense y esa cosa audiencia fue
nominada de ley en 2 de noviembre todos
los 144 avistamientos fueron registrados
en vídeo entre 2004 y 2001 y muestran un
vuelo inusual
[Música]
el informe dice que esto puede deberse
en algunos casos a destellos del sensor
o análisis pobres de los pilotos o
aviones y aves que pueden confundir a un
radar pero lo que el pentágono más teme
es que se trata de una tecnología
desarrollada por otro país la
probabilidad más alta es que se trata de
un programa de observación si esos jets
tácticos de otros países están por ahí
es un problema inmenso las agencias de
inteligencia temen que china o rusia
estén probando tecnologías hipersónicas
porque algunos de estos objetos se
mueven rápido el lenguaje del reporte
del pentágono evita mencionar posible
vida extraterrestre pero no la descarta
todavía tampoco lo hacen los pilotos
estadounidenses
la forma en la que está maniobrando la
forma en la que está acelerando parece
tener capacidades que nuestros sistemas
no han podido mostrar o lograr
así que ciertamente para mí en ese
momento fue impactante escuchar a la
naturaleza de dichos incidentes sigue
sin ser explicada de acuerdo con el jefe
del comité de inteligencia del senado
sólo han aumentado en los últimos tres
años
y nos despedimos en colombia donde se
cumplieron cinco años de la intervención
de un sector de bogotá conocido como el
bronx así operaban sin la banda de
delincuentes traficantes y también
consumidores de drogas el sector
atraviesa ahora un proceso de
transformación no para borrar su
historia sino para resignificar la
veamos el informe de nuestro equipo en
la capital colombiana
este era el bronx de bogotá un lugar que
a pesar de su cercanía con la sede del
gobierno local y nacional era
considerado como una república
independiente donde se comercializaban
libremente drogas y se perpetraban
crímenes atroces como descuartizamientos
de personas esclavitud sexual secuestros
y extorsiones
así luce ahora después de que el
ejército de colombia y la policía lo
intervinieran en 2016 hoy este lugar
vive una transformación con miras a
convertirlo en un distrito creativo el
bronx distrito creativo es uno de los
distritos creativos de la red que tiene
bogotá es el primero inducido y lo que
estamos haciendo es resignificar un
espacio a partir del reconocimiento de
las vocaciones locales del arte la
cultura y el emprendimiento levantaremos
un nuevo edificio que hemos llamado el
edificio creativo que son 17 mil metros
cuadrados y que nos permitirá tener un
espacio de 35 mil para el emprendimiento
para los talleres para la circulación
para la creación que es tan importante y
para el reconocimiento de los oficios
gracias al proceso de recuperación el
sector también conocido como la l
respira un nuevo aire pero se trata de
resignificar la zona no de borrar su
historia un componente muy importante de
este proyecto es la memoria y una
memoria que la construyamos con la misma
gente y que a través de herramientas
artísticas contemos esta historia
nuestra esquina redonda es nuestro
espacio
para construir con la comunidad
vulnerable con los residentes con los
comerciantes con los ex habitantes de
calles que habitaron el bronx pero en
una memoria oscura del bronx sin una
memoria positiva en donde esa gente que
habitó allí también encontró un lugar
seguro para ellos y es una labor que no
sólo le corresponde a las autoridades
sino a la comunidad por esto hay un
llamado a los jóvenes de bogotá a
participar por una beca con la que
puedan expresar su arte y a la vez ser
parte de este renacer muchísimas gracias
por acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
américa en la producción estuvieron luís
fernando montes y natalia cabrera
recuerden que pueden ver este y muchos
otros programas en france24 punto com
[Música]